et vous l'avez peut-être vu à l'entrée
de nazel Négron la circulation est
alternée sur la départementale 952 car
des travaux sont en cours fustine
l'aménagement d'une plage panoramique
sur 8 hectares en bord de Loire vient de
débuter un projet à 400000 € portés par
le département d'indrloire et la région
Centre depuis cette fenêtre sur la Loire
il sera possible d'admirer le château
d'Amboise et de profiter sans le dégradé
d'un site naturel d'exception les îles
et les rives de la Loire étant classé au
patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO Clémence
Dosque repoussé entre autres par le
covid et l'obtention d'autorisation le
chantier de la plage panoramique de
nazel Négron vient tout juste de débuter
sur la rive en face il faut rafraîchir
les mémoires je savais pas j'étais même
pas courant c'est pas mal comme idé moi
je trouve ça bien oui par ici on a quand
même suremboiss beaucoup plus
d'aménagement pour les touristes mais il
faudrait partager un peu les touristes
sur le tout le long de la Loire en bois
c'est tellement touristique que ça va
encore faire venir beaucoup de gens même
des gens de tour parce que nous on
habite tour mais on viendra certainement
he c'est sûr à côté de la départementale
952 la plage en bord de Loire est un
espace classé Natura 2000 et riche de
biodiversité pour la préserver le
département a impulsé le projet fenêtre
sur Loire un aménagement sans
artificialisation d'une promenade d'un
km avec un point de vue dégagé sur le
château d'emboise le belved sera réservé
au promeneurs et accessible au PMR un
lieu d'attractivité pour la ville de
nazel Négron qui ne débourse pas pour le
chantier la mairie travaille sur la
gestion des flux de circulation engendré
par ce nouvel espace c'est une plage
ouverte à tous et à toutes euh qui
permettait d'aller promener son chien de
descendre en voiture en camping-car mais
il faut se rappeler quand même que c'est
une zone importante de biodiversité nous
sommes dans le lit majeur de la Loire et
il fallait absolument réguler cela et
arrêter de tout détruire partager entre
la région et le département le coût de
ce projet s'élève à 372000 € toute taxe
comprise une parcelle de de l'autre côté
de la départementale va être acheté pour
yaménager un parking la promenade sera
accessible au printemps